der grausame doppelmord an zwei jungen
polizisten bei kusel in rheinland pfalz
so grausam und so sinnlos weil sie nur
sterben mussten weil zwei wilderer nicht
entdeckt werden wollten der prozess
beginnen heute ein paukenschlag viele
zuschauer glaubten sie hätten nicht
richtig auf
diesen moment hatten die menschen hier
im landgericht kaiserslautern gewartet
andreas s der mutmaßliche doppelmörder
von krusell betritt den gerichtssaal
der mann der zwei junge menschen
kaltblütig erschossen haben soll die
24-jährige polizeianwärterin jasmin b
und den 29-jährigen oberkommissar
alexander kam hier geht's für die
angeklagten oder für den satz für einen
um lebenslänglich die angehörigen haben
schon lebenslänglich die familien der
opfer treten als nebenkläger auf
allerdings nur in form ihrer anwälte die
anwälte haben ihn nämlich geraten dem
prozess fern zu bleiben weil es werden
natürlich im verlauf der verhandlung
ganz grausame details der taten
geschildert werden und dann geschieht
etwas womit niemand gerechnet hätte
andreas es weist jede schuld von sich
behauptet reist er hätte aus notwehr
gehandelt versucht nun den mord seinem
komplizen florian v in die schuhe zu
schieben der ebenfalls auf der
anklagebank gesetzt
florian v soll in der tat nach dabei und
an der bilderreihe beteiligt gewesen
sein weil mandant hat mit erleben müssen
dass zwei junge menschen von dem
mitangeklagten getötet wurden ohne dass
er etwas dagegen tun konnte er wurde
danach selber gedroht dass wenn er nicht
weiter kooperiert er neben die beiden
getöteten gelegt wird florian frau
befindet sich auf freiem fuß ist er
tatsächlich auch opfer von andreas s
perfider brutalität oder versucht auch
er nur sich von jeder schuld
reinzuwaschen
fakt ist an der tatwaffe einem
jagdgewehr wurde nur die dna von andreas
s nachgewiesen deshalb ist die
staatsanwaltschaft auch sicher andreas s
hat den doppelmord an den polizisten
allein begangen das soll aus habgier
oder auch aus
dragons absicht geschehen sein aus
habgier weil er seine beute sein
jagdbeute sichern wollte und zur
verdeckung der versuchten tötung zum
nachteil der polizei anwärterin wie
eiskalt der 39-jährige angeklagte
offenbar ist zeigt vor allem ein
unfassbares detail nachdem er die junge
polizeianwärterin tod glaubt durchsucht
er sie nach einem notizbuch das ihn
belasten könnte dabei bemerkt er dass
sie noch lebt und schießt ihr ein
weiteres mal in den kopf
der polizisten doppelmord von kusel ein
verbrechen das an vitalität und
grausamkeit wohl kaum zu übertreffen ist
ein urteil wird nicht vor dem herbst
erwartet